on va jouer maintenant les chéris quatre
propositions comme hier bien entendu on
va jouer et on va jouer avec toute
l'actualité du jour Chantal Goya on s'en
va juste après en plus donc on joue avec
Chantal aussi question une Elon Musk est
en train de développer un projet fou
lequel envoyer tous les rats de New York
dans l'espace commercialiser des fusées
pour le grand public implanter une puce
dans le cerveau humain organisé un
octogone entre Joe Biden et Kim Jong-un
alors à votre avis allez c'est la puce
dans le cerveau humain exactement c'est
son objectif c'est d'implanter des puces
dans le cerveau humain afin de faire
communiquer directement le cerveau et un
ordinateur c'est un truc de fou ça
regarde regardez regardez une puce
d'environ 8 mm implantées dans le
cerveau le fantasme d'Elon musk devient
de plus en plus crédible la technologie
consiste à placer un implant de la
taille d'une pièce d'un euro dans le
cerveau et qui la puce va capter
des signaux nerveux et en stimuler
certaines parties la start-up va donc
pouvoir commencer à recruter pour des
essais cliniques il s'agira dans un
premier temps des personnes paralysées
ou souffrant de maladies neurologiques
plutôt pas mal mais c'est arrêté ça a
été testé sur beaucoup d'animaux dans
des conditions qui sont pour moi
inhumaines on a mis des implants collés
à la glue directement sur le cerveau de
singe on a installé sur des mauvaises
vertèbres des implants sur des cochons
enfin bref il y a quand même de la
souffrance animale qui a été voilà subie
avant qu'on teste sur des êtres humains
donc je suis quand même assez mitigé je
sais pas si vous en pensez mais tu
préfères pas quand même compter sur les
animaux bah je pense qu'il y a des
façons de faire on peut tester sans
alors là
je trouve entre tester sur les animaux
pour tester des rouges à lèvres ou là
c'est des lamentable et tester pour vous
guérir des parasites là c'est pas la
même chose
qui malheureusement sont morts il a créé
le vaccin grâce à ça c'est l'histoire de
la science on peut tester sur des
humains alors
en fait les tests j'ai lu ça sur un site
enfin sur CNN pour pour le citer il
commence les tests cette semaine sur des
patients paralysés et donc là voilà
exactement et donc là grâce à
l'intervention de l'interface l'avenir
l'idée c'est de pouvoir les animaux tout
simplement volontaire malheureusement
non mais là ce qu'on reprend l'enjeu il
est énorme ce qu'on reproche c'est pas
qu'il est testé sur les animaux c'est
que le protocole a manqué d'éthique donc
ce qu'il est testé sur les animaux ça
c'est évidemment inhérent à la science
malheureusement on est obligé de passer
par là mais ce qu'on reproche c'est la
façon dont il l'a fait parce que il la
morte le taux de mortalité des animaux a
été éminemment supérieur à ce que ça
aurait du tel voilà c'est ça un
chimpanzé ou un homme donc c'est
scandaleux
mais c'est du sacrifice d'animaux moi je
rejoins je rejoins Valérie à terme on va
tous devenir des cobayes d'Elon musk on
dirait un mauvais épisode de Black
Mirror ça me fait peur merci voilà lui
parle bien voilà
il parle bien allez au-dessus d'un
chimpanzé merci merci et surtout si de
d'intervenir
[Rires]
de plus en plus con
allez quelle invention improbable à
gagner un prix scientifique majeur des
lunettes avec essuie-glace un slip auto
nettoyant
un décodeur de bafouille de Jean-Michel
maire ou des toilettes à reconnaissance
d'anus
mais j'ai bien sur les toilettes pour
reconnaître les anus ça ressemble
paierait que ce soit ça me pleurer
pour faire ça
[Applaudissements]
a gagné un prix scientifique pour ses
toilettes intelligentes et reconnaissent
votre anus et analyse vos selles et
votre rire pour savoir si tout est ok
moi je trouve ça regardez regardez
elles peuvent aussi servir à notre santé
merci à tous pour cette honneur et
n'oubliez pas ne gâchez pas vos déchets
alors
c'est fou ah oui c'est bien parce que ça
va permettre d'analyser si on a des
maladies je trouve ça formidable ça
c'est une avancée technologique
extraordinaire merci oui vous avez dû
reconnu des anus bonsoir c'est ce qui
est vrai c'est que la lutte c'est un peu
comme la pupille de l'oeil on a personne
n'a le même anus c'est
très bien on montre l’œil on pourrait
très bien montrer son anus à l'aéroport
ane c'est une preuve irréfutable il y a
un nombre de plis c'est un peu comme un
code barre si vous vous montrez votre
anus là je vais vous dire mais je peux
mémoriser votre état anal et on en
retrouvera dans
la vérité
si on monte on monte tous les deux on
verra qu'on a pas le même par exemple
[Musique]
[Rires]
elles sont bizarres toutes ces
expériences
pourquoi une femme a-t-elle été recalée
d'un poste d'enseignante à cause de son
odeur corporelle parce qu'elle a indiqué
avoir 55 ans alors qu'en réalité elle en
avait 85 la cause de son passé de
strip-teaseuse ou parce qu'elle a fait
un tu l'as vu au proviseur qui n'a pas
kiffé d'eau
c'est vraiment triste et ça dit beaucoup
de choses beaucoup de notre époques
c'est pas ça à Paris cette femme de 85
ans elle voulait juste retravailler en
fait c'est donc à la menti de 30 ans sur
au moment de l'application enfin au
moment de de sa candidature
mais évidemment lorsqu'elle est arrivée
devant
le responsable de l'établissement
scolaire non il s'est aperçu qu'elle
avait beaucoup plus et donc elle a
jamais dispensé de cours elle aurait pu
être elle aurait pu et c'est triste en
fait parce que voilà elle voulait elle
voulait travailler savoir qu'en France
il y a des gens qui veulent travailler à
85 ans et je trouve ça je trouve ça
dommage parce que
je trouve ça dommage parce que il peut
sortir
[Rires]
oui Delphine oui c'est dommage parce
qu'aujourd'hui en France on manque
d'enseignants donc c'est cette femme à
toute sa tête et la capacité de pouvoir
transmettre c'est dommage qu'on a pas
laissé faire la question c'est est-ce
qu'elle a envie de travailler ou est-ce
qu'elle y va parce qu'elle a une
retraite minable c'est ce qui l'empêche
de vivre décemment c'est vraiment ça en
fait le vrai le curseur il est vraiment
là
on fait plus des signes comme ça
discrètement
ça marche pas avec moi
[Rires]
ça marche pas
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-il arrivé à une femme après
s'être licencie elle a gagné à
l'euromillion elle a posé une pêche sur
le bureau du DRH elle a vidé le compte
de la société avant de partir ou alors
comme 80% des chômeurs intégrer l'équipe
de chroniqueurs de TPMP
elle a gagné une somme extraordinaire à
l’euro millions elle venait juste d'être
virée elle avait joué occasionnellement
c'est une histoire folle comme quoi
elle a su au départ elle pensait qu'elle
allait gagner quelques dizaines d'euros
quand elle s'est rendu compte du coup
elle s'est dit qu'est-ce que je vais
faire de mon ticket elle l'a gardé dans
son sac et elle gardait son sac partout
elle tombait la pelouse avec le Samsung
[Musique]
[Rires]
c'est une idée
c'est une vraie question est-ce qu'on le
met le ticket avant d'aller à la
française des jeux
9 millions
c'est vrai que quand j'ai vu ça je me
suis dit l'ordre des choses tombe la
pelouse avant d'aller récupérer tes 109
millions c'est vrai que c'est moi j'ai
pas du tout envie de récupérer la enfin
la pelouse
pour valider il faut vérifier et après
vous allez quand vous êtes un grand
gagnant voilà exactement la France il
faut bien le planquer
un peu pourquoi tu me regardes comme ça
toi c'est un problème
parce que je trouve ça stupide ce que tu
dis si ça t'arrive le soir et le
lendemain matin tu es à 8 heures du
matin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à mon avis à mon avis c'est pour rien il
avait préparé il avait il avait préparé
je pensais il s'est dit tiens demain
vous voulez que je prépare à quoi pas
besoin de préparer avec eux
non mais quoi tu dois attendre combien
de temps mais tu dois attendre un petit
délai
de la Française des jeux non mais quand
tu as une série de 8h du matin non mais
quand tu as une somme aussi calle au sol
il y a ça c'est marrant mais cette
question je me suis toujours posé
qu'est-ce que je fais entre le moment où
je je me rends compte que j'ai gagné je
te jure je crois que je dors pas je
garde le truc comme ça j'y vais tout de
suite
moi je dors pas moi aussi
moi je vais voir la personne qui me l'a
vendu et puis je commence à faire la
fête avec lui et puis je vais partager
avec lui
dans le tabac à l'Euromillions tu es
chez toi devant ta télé quand tu la
prends non c'est pas la campagne
moi j'appelle la mafia parce que la
plupart des gens qui gagnent de
l'Euromillions ils gagnent 109 vous
pouvez leur vendre 120 millions la mafia
parce que c'est une manière de blanchir
l'argent il donne 120 millions ou
gagnant ils prennent le ticket ils vont
toucher son poids
c'est une info
[Applaudissements]
malhonnête mais pas plus vite
alors on se retrouve dans un instant
avec les infos du jour à tout de suite
[Applaudissements]